much more important story than whatever
is going on in the GOP
race these little guys these little six
Millie lip pillies you know what I'm
talking about I'm talking
about Zin Chuck
Schumer top Democrat out there in the
Senate one of the leading Democrats in
this country for
decades he wants to take away your tasty
little nicotine pouches Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer is calling for
federal action to crack down on a
product called Zen he says the nicotine
pouches pose a danger to teens as they
use them as an alternative to
ecigarettes pouch packed with problems
high levels of nicotine so today I'm
delivering a warning to parents because
these nicotine pouches seem to lock
their sights on young kids teenagers and
even lower and then use the social media
to hook them Senator Schumer is urging
the FTC and the FDA to invest
investigate Zen for concerns relating to
marketing and health effects we reached
out to Zen for comment but have not yet
heard
back I agree with almost everything
Senator Schumer just said these little
nicotine pouches they can pack a punch
some of them just basically have the
same dose of nicotine as a single
cigarette but some it's more like three
cigarettes or four cigarettes or more so
I I
agree I'm not the leader of Zimbabwe
okay I didn't lead a revolution in
brodia to become the leader of that
state I'm not the prime minister of
zindia I'm not I'm not even the mayor of
Cincinnati but I've popped in a nice
little lip py every now and again and
it's amazing I you I think that's
actually what neural link will feel like
it feels like you're just taking an
electrical charge and plugging it into
your brain stem and then all your
synapses fire on again and you just
start working I have a friend of mine
who is now hopelessly addicted to Zen he
says that that substance makes him a
better husband and a better father and
now he no longer needs these
trivialities these silly little things
like sleep he can just stay awake all
the time and be very productive and it's
but so I agree it's extremely addictive
young people are getting hooked on it I
to and I'm not I'm not saying that's
good but I'm just a little confused that
Chuck Schumer's coming after the Zin
because Chuck Schumer here just about a
year and a half ago partnered up with
other top Democrats in the Senate to try
to legalize pot
the Cannabis Administration and
Opportunity Act this comprehensive
legislation would end Federal cannabis
prohibition by removing cannabis from
the Controlled Substances
Act Empower states to create their own
cannabis laws ensure Federal Regulation
protect Public Safety and Health how are
you going you're going to protect Public
Safety and Health by legalizing by
encouraging a substance that not only is
a gateway to other harder drugs but just
in itself makes people really fat and
dumb and slow and is extremely addictive
even though all the potheads say it's
not addictive at all but these are the
people who always insist that marijuana
is not addictive are the ones who wake
and bake and just rip the
old California cumin I don't know I'm
running out of terms for pot but they
they do it all day long oh man it's not
addictive I could quit any time and it's
my whole
personality it cures every dis
man and Chuck Schumer wants to legalize
that if you legalize pot who do you
think is going to use it you think it's
just going to be a granny for the first
time is going to spark up a bong no I
think kids largely are going to use it
in exactly the same way that kids are
now testing out these Zin packets I
don't think that's a good thing but why
is Schumer okay with one and not the
other Tucker had a great monologue on
this a while ago I don't think he was
the first person to point up but he
articulated what a lot of us were
thinking which is that
today marijuana is left coated marijuana
is a thing that Libs do I know there are
PL there plenty of people who listen to
this show who love just puffing on the
old Devil's lettuce
but broadly speaking it's a left-wing
thing and broadly speaking nicotine is a
right-wing thing the cigars and the
pipes and even the cigarettes today are
a right-wing thing yes there are people
on the left who smoke tobacco and use
nicotine
mostly it's right wing you think of some
you know uh big cowboy hat wearing good
old boy from the down South we in
wearing spurs on his boots and packing a
big fat lucky Lipper of dip that's not a
left-wing person that's not some vegan
lesbian in Brooklyn that's a
right-winger so that's how it's coded
now and Chuck Schumer supports the
left-wing substance and the leftwing
substance coincidentally makes you kind
of lazy and dumb and passive as Tucker
noted in his is viral monologue and the
right-wing substance makes you more
alert it makes you uh think more quickly
and more clearly it it uh keeps you up
so that you can do more work it's it's
not it's not a party drug you know it's
not the sort of thing where you just put
on some stupid cartoon and eat a bowl of
ice cream when you know when you when
you're thrown in Zin packets or even
ripping cigarettes or something like
that it's the image you get is someone
who's who's frenetic it's someone who's
who's really active and and that's a
right-wing thing that's why and so the
reason that Schumer and the Democrats
are going after this I think is not even
just because they in part it's because
they want to encourage people to be
passive and lazy and dumb but e even
more than that it's because they want to
support their own tabos and they want to
oppose the right-wing tabos they want to
support their own standards they want to
oppose the right-wing
standards that this is the exact same
point I've made with free speech notably
in my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds thank you the battle
here is not between free speech on the
one hand and sensorship on the other
it's about competing sets of standards
and Norms it's the same thing with the
substances I don't even really like Zen
I mean I'm making a lot of Zen puns
right now but I don't like any addictive
substances really I don't have an
addictive personality I love cigars but
I I I am not just saying I could quit
anytime I actually have quit for very
long periods and you don't feel any
physical Drive like it but you take them
or leave them okay tobacco has there's a
good piece by the Theologian Mike Foley
who points out that tobacco relates in a
way to the tripartite soul the tobacco
pipe that's like the logical part of
your soul you think of the philosopher
you think of the stem and the bowl the
male and the female then the cigars
they're the
thotics you know they relate to the
chest you puff it out you don't really
inhale it ever and cigarettes and I
guess you'd include Zin and dip in that
that's more the repetitive part of the
soul I don't like the appetitive stuff I
don't like anything that's really
addictive but I would much rather live
in a culture that exalts working hard
and being more alert and being more
conscious and uh uh being more
fastidious about your work than a
culture that supports the chum gang and
munchies and giggling at stupid cartoons
and getting fat and voting for Democrats
and that's what it's about it's what it
comes down to to for Schumer he wants to
he wants to oppose the right-wing
substances promote the left-wing
substances oppose the right-wing rituals
support the left-wing rituals because I
if you create a culture that is leftwing
you're going to get more left-wing
voters the Texas National Guard has
responded to a Supreme Court ruling
which uh ruled that the Biden
Administration is permitted to tear
down modest border fencing that the
Texas National Guard
had erected to try to stop the foreign
Invasion into Texas to try to protect
Texas's territorial Integrity the Texas
National Guard has
responded by rebuilding the fence I love
this this is so great Biden won't
enforce the Border Biden actually
encourages foreign Nationals to flood
across into our country into Texas in
large part uh because it will give him
more votes down the line record numbers
never seen anything like it in America
twice what we saw under
Obama and Texas says okay you're not
going to enforce the Border we're going
to build a little fence and then Biden
orders his feds to go in and tear down
the fencing he wants to make it easier
for the foreign Nationals to invade the
country run by the cartels by the way
we're not even just talking about you
know a nice young family fleeing poverty
we're talking about the cartels so he
tears that down and then Texas says okay
cool that's great that you made your uh
decision Supreme Court we're going to
put it back up
again this is how the country was set up
you you know you're going to hear the
libs say Texas doesn't support the rule
of law they're a threat to our sacred
democracy there no
Texas what Texas is doing is far more in
line with the founding vision of America
than anything you've seen out of
Washington in recent years Texas is
enacting federalism subsidiarity
protecting that which is most local most
dear why do we have a federal system in
America why do we have power reserved at
least in theory to the states and the
counties and the townships and the local
communities and the family ultimately
because of a deeper principle called
subsidiarity According to which we know
that people are going to be most
accountable to things that are near to
them that are dear to them their family
and their extended family you know their
tribe their kin their Community their
state they're going to be much less
accountable to the to the national
government and the national government's
going to be much less accountable to
them so we're going to try to keep power
at as local a level as possible at at
the sort of level at which that power
can be efficiently and justly wielded
Texas is doing that I hope more more
States follow suit man what a great clip
that was now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time